Okay, so here's a probability distribution I'm going to define
for you Michael. You'll notice that it's a probability over
our Xs. And it's parameterized by theta. So theta is
going to turn out to stand for threshold. Okay? Got it?
>> Mmhm.
>> Okay, so here's a probability distribution. It is 1 over z sub theta. For
all values of x such that the fitness
function is greater than or equal to theta.
>> Yeah.
>> And it's 0 otherwise. So do you understand that?
>> I think so. So I assume that Z sub
theta here is, is going to be some kind of normalization factor that
accounts for the probability of landing or choosing an x
in that space. In the space of high-scoring individuals above threshold.
>> That's exactly right. So another way of saying this is that the this
probability is uniform over all values of x whose
fitness are above some threshold.
>> Yeah so, I'm, I'm, the image I have in my
hand is kind of like a mountain range and if you
put a slice through it then everything that's kind of above
that slice, if we are going to sample uniformly from that, that collection.
>> That's right. And everything below it, we will simply ignore.
>> Doesn't happen, it doesn't get sampled form.
>> Exactly. Okay so because you demanded it Michael, here's a quiz.
>> [LAUGH] Alright.
>> So,
two questions in this quiz. The first question
is, theta's some threshold and so let's imagine the
fitness function has to have some minimum value
and some maximum value. Okay? And let's call those
theta submin and theta submax respectively. And so I want you to
describe in one or two words P sup data
min of x. That is the probability distribution whether threshold is its minimum
value, and P sup data max of x. That is, the
distribution where theta is at it's maximum value. You got it?
>> So, just to, just to be clear,
sort of the maximum meaningful and minimum meaningful values
>> Right.
>> Because I can imagine them, you know, if it's just sort of
way outside the range of the fitness
function then it's kind of trivial, I guess.
>> Right, well, let's, it is, but let's assume that theta min is the
lowest value that the fitness function can take on and theta max is the largest
value of the fitness function.
>> Okay, yeah, okay, that's how I was imagining it.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, yeah, I'm good to go.
>> Okay. So go!